this has the whiff of August 1945
somebody just used a new weapon and this
weapon will not be put back into the box
in his latest film zero days Academy
award-winning documentarian Alex Gibney
delved into the creation and deployment
of the Stuxnet virus and act give me
believes is a game-changing moment in
cyber warfare Stuxnet was a
self-replicating virus a worm piece of
malware that was launched by the US and
Israel into the centrifuges of the
Natanz nuclear plant in Iran and its
purpose was to secretly make the
centrifuges spin out of control until
they blew up but to send messages back
to the engineers that all was well so it
was both a weapon of destruction but it
was also meant to sow doubt in the minds
of the scientists the reason it's hugely
significant is is the first time the
computer code has crossed the threshold
from the realm of cyber to the realm of
the physical and starts blowing stuff up
it seems to me from the film Stuxnet
worked in the beginning and it was only
after according to NSA officials on
background they said that Israel
basically warped the code was it bad to
produce was it bad for the United States
to go into that sphere look it's a good
question and frankly personally and I
know a lot of other people feel the same
way as a weapon it was a brilliant and
elegant weapon which achieved a goal of
slowing down Iran's path to being a
nuclear power however as a precedent it
was extremely dangerous because it was
an attack on critical infrastructure in
peacetime that had been done to us we
would have been within our rights to
start a war and so if you're saying well
it's okay now we're setting a new norm
to launch a cyber weapon on critical
infrastructure whenever we feel like it
that's a dangerous norm because that
becomes the norm for everybody and one
of the most disquieting things about
Stuxnet is how far beyond Stuxnet the
sophistication of the weapons have
become and their use the the two people
who discovered Stuxnet the beginning of
Eric and and Liam from Symantec they
would see one or two state-sponsored
attacks in say 2010 now they see over
hundred what makes cyber warfare the
same and different than traditional
orphan it's interesting that cyber
weapons can only be launched with the
permission of the President of the
United States that makes them analogous
entirely to nuclear weapons the nuclear
analogy can be overdrawn but I think
it's important to understand because in
cyber war I mean obviously there's
certain element to this we can always
understand it goes way back to signals
intelligence that is to say things like
capturing radio signals of the enemy and
being able to understand where they're
going or possibly jamming them now with
cyber weapons it goes beyond espionage
though it starts as an espionage tool it
goes beyond espionage to be able to take
control of machines and cause physical
destruction so in war you can understand
how hugely valuable that would be but
also how dangerous it is so you want you
know the anti-aircraft guns or
surface-to-air missiles you take down
the electrical grid that supplies that
power and suddenly that's a great
strategic weapon the problem is that you
may also take down hospitals and other
things of that nature that could cause a
lot of civilian deaths so the potential
for enormous destruction and loss of
life is is palpable there when it comes
to cyber weapons the other interesting
element I think that nobody is really
focused on is the Department of Justice
I've issued indictments I believe for a
number of Iranians for having launched a
cyber at
on American banks I found that ironic
considering the fact that we could
logically assume that there will soon be
indictments on certain members of the
NSA for having launched a cyber attack
on Iran this is the tricky part you know
there there's there's the technical
aspect of these weapons but then there's
the law and and this is that this is
what takes you in into the torture
debate into the drone debate and all of
that other stuff people can talk about
techniques all they want but at some
point you have to begin to talk about
reciprocity the law and values and
that's where the rubber meets the road
in many ways this film is a detective
story but it's also a story about
transparency and secrecy yes we know
that Stuxnet was launched by Israel and
the United States against Iran the
United States won't admit that Israel
won't admit that sometimes people in
Israel do so with a kind of wink and nod
but officially they won't admit it and
that's problematic in and of itself
because it already happened we know it
happened we know who did it
but still nobody will admit it since the
event has already happened why can't we
talk more openly and publicly about
Stuxnet yeah I mean my answer is because
it's classified
I won't knowledge you knowingly offer up
anything I consider classified you can
talk much about Stuxnet this incident is
officially classified you're right on
both those counts but there has been lot
reported in the press I don't want to
comment on this I read things a
newspapers in the media like you but I'm
unable to elaborate upon it people might
find it frustrating not to be able to
talk about when it's in the public
domain but
I find it frustrating yeah I'm sure you
do I don't answer that question
unfortunately I can't comment I don't
know how to answer that two answers
before you get started I don't know and
if I did we wouldn't talk about anyway
we have a situation now where the
weapons have gone way beyond Stuxnet in
terms of their sophistication and their
destructive power yet by keeping that
offensive cyber capability secret we
deprive everybody in this country in a
democracy of having any kind of debate
over how and when and why they should be
used so the secrecy has is actually
putting us at existential risk in this
case who do you blame for the secrecy
the obsession with secrecy has has
increased exponentially from the Bush
administration out of the Obama
administration who know that the Obama
administration which claimed that it was
going to be the most transparent
administration in history was going to
prosecute more leakers than any of all
the previous administrations combined so
there has been a kind of momentum for
secrecy that which is understandable I
suppose but I think we have to resist it
because now so much is secret that it
becomes a kind of default position so we
have a kind of opaque government that no
longer responds to the will or consent
of the people what about the individual
is someone who doesn't have faith in
large government institutions I mean
should we be hoarding water and growing
crisis gardens like what's what's the
answer for the individual here look
there are a few things we want is that
we should be properly cautious about
using our computers and the internet
because of the enormous destructive
power that is abroad in the land and the
way that the Internet has been
militarized it's scary but we should be
conscious of it more fundamentally you
know these cyber weapons which are not
being talked about by our own government
can put us at X
essential risk we have to raise our
voices in a democracy to say we got to
have a discussion about this my kids are
at risk my way of life is at risk and
you're not copping to me about the
nature of that risk or what you're doing
about it so in that context I think we
should all be furious a number of your
films zero-days smartest guys in the
room
maiya Maxima culpa going clear they
center around sort of shadowy groups
with worldwide often illegal secret
plans what draws you to these stories
which I think must be inherently
difficult because of the sprawling
nature and the secrecy behind them and
also do you consider yourself a
conspiracy factual list cuz yeah I don't
really believe and I'm not you're right
I'm not a conspiracy theorist in the
sense that usually conspiracy theories
revolve around supreme intelligence that
is somehow masterminding and I don't
have that much confidence in people's
intelligence to get that right so that's
where the conspiracy theories when we
usually fall down but I am interested in
abuses of power and part of power and
abusing power usually has to do with
secrecy and so you have to pierce that
veil of secrecy or try to in order to be
able to get at and to understand those
abuses are you optimistic that this will
get worked out or are you pessimistic in
the short term I'm pessimistic but
hopeful as Richard Clarke says in the
film everybody said we couldn't do
agreements relating to nuclear weapons
we did it was everyone said the same
thing about chemical weapons we did I
think we can get it right with cyber
weapons but we have to have the will to
do it and right now the norm as a former
NSA jag also says in the film is that
there should be no norm that there are
no rules and that's not a very good norm
that puts us all at risk
you